Cómo se verían afectados los intereses
de Rusia si Finlandia y Suecia
finalmente decide en ingresar a la otan
bien bueno buenas tardes gracias por por
la comunicación bien es importante tener
en cuenta que digamos uno podía dividir
los países europeos en relación con
Rusia en cuatro grandes grupos los de
extremo occidente digamos la Península
ibérica el Reino Unido quizás son países
que tienen muy poca cercanía con Rusia y
digamos lo que ocurre en Rusia les
resulta un poco más irrelevante como
casi como estando fuera del continente
luego tenemos el centro de Europa que
depende de Rusia en gran parte Alemania
principalmente es el país más grande que
depende de los suministros de gas de
Rusia
el este de Europa los seis países de
Europa del este o los seis países de la
unión soviética tiene una relación
extremadamente conflictiva con Rusia
Rusia ha sido el Imperio que los ha
intentado dominar y tiene una relación
muy conflictiva y luego los países
denominadas neutrales que luego la
Segunda Guerra no optaron por estar
digamos claramente son por supuesto
países capitalistas democracias
liberales pero no no estuvieron ninguna
de las dos grandes la esperanza de
posguerra el Pacto de Varsovia el lado
soviético y la otan del lado occidental
estos países son por ejemplo Austria
Finlandia Suecia hoy lo que ha producido
la acción rusa es que Finlandia Iglesias
estén considerando abandonar su
neutralidad esto por supuesto afecta a
Rusia en tantos países históricamente
neutrales como Finlandia principalmente
que limita con Rusia o Suecia han
decidido a partir de lo que ha hecho
Rusia bueno evaluar la posibilidad de
abandonar una histórica neutralidad que
ya lleva más de 70 años